this is alien where's all new area 51 a
gargantuan gaming PC with enough power
under its unique triad chassis to blaze
through even the most demanding of PC
games sporting one of Intel's Haswell
processors and x99 chipset along with
three of them videos gtx 980 graphics
cards the area 51 is all about
leading-edge technology
naturally that comes at a price the
Alienware comes in multiple
configurations for the one I'm testing
here is the most expensive coming in at
four thousand five hundred and forty
nine dollars it features and 1500 watt
power supply 256 gigabyte Samsung SSD a
4 terabyte hard drive 16 gigabytes of mm
133 megahertz ddr4 Ram intel core i7 59
30 K processor with a modest overclock
to 3.9 gigahertz and 3 NVIDIA GTX 980
graphics cards that's a hugely powerful
machine by any measure but it's worth
noting that you're paying quite a
premium for the case standing at over 22
inches tall over 9 inches wide and over
25 inches in depth
it's an imposing machine even by gaming
PC standards the Triad design does have
some practical benefits though for
starters both the rear and front panel
IO sit up at an angle which makes it
easier to plug into accessories and
displays you can also tilt the whole
thing forward for even easier access the
easily removable latch side panels
reveal a neat and tidy interior which
features two front intake fans one at
the top of the case and one near the
bottom the blows air towards the GPUs
the CPU is called by an all-in-one
liquid cooler with 120 mm radiator and
fans set to exhaust at the top the case
all of the drives including the slim
blu-ray writer are located behind the
motherboard with mounts available for 2
SSD
and a further three hard drives even if
you don't configure the system with all
those drives in place Alienware pre
mounts the cables you need to hook them
up which is a nice touch
sadly the drive bays aren't tool free so
you'll need to dig out some screws and a
screwdriver to get them in and out
similarly disappointing are the modular
cables which are your basic mismatched
OAM set and again given the cost is odd
not to see a more aesthetically pleasing
and sturdy a set of wrapped cables
inside the internal design does have its
benefits for airflow though by putting
the drives behind the motherboard tray
air can travel unobstructed over the
GPUs and CPU cooler idle CPU
temperatures average just below 40
degrees centigrade and under load rarely
pushed over 60
with three gtx 980m haswell-e
on board there's no surprise at the area
51 breezes through even the most
demanding of games at 1080p and 1440p at
4k in this case using invidious dynamic
super resolution technology the system
just the prank pushes over 60 frames per
second in most games but it still
couldn't quite manage the same with
Metro last light and Crysis 3 clearly 4k
at a consistent 60 frames per second is
still out of reach for this GPU
generation even with three cards in tow
so there's no arguing with the
performance of the area 51 for the most
part of what else would you expect from
cream-of-the-crop PC components this is
a supremely powerful machine one that
will be just as good for video editing
and 3d rendering work as it would for
playing the latest shooter annoyingly
even on cheaper versions of the machine
you can't spec it out within videos
cheaper GTX 970 GPUs which would shave
hundreds of dollars off the price you
either have to pick the pricey gtx 980
or go with older cards like the gtx 770
or 780 quite why the 970 isn't an option
is a mystery so while the area 51's case
may be to your tastes as usual the smart
option is to build your own PC but only
can you save several hundred dollars but
you can actually build a more powerful
computer too still if you must go
pre-built the area 51 is a well designed
quiet machine for the price that
compares favorably with systems from the
likes of origin and digital storm and as
such is one of the best pre-built
options out there